but personal growth when you look at
that if you you know if you consider
other avenues of personal growth they're
usually not that Pleasant right so in
general the purpose of personal growth
in its very definition if you believe in
personal growth means that you're going
to be in moments of increased pressure
that will either cause you to break or
grow that's what personal growth is
about how the motivations for personal
growth can be anywhere from really
healthy to really [ __ ] up right so
when you come from a place of I'm not
good enough and hence I need to grow
that's a battle you can never win you
know you can do Tony Robbins whatever
the Platinum Club and and you know do
your daily affirmations and do your
whatever what are those workouts called
px something whatever you know those
things and then you can like pray and
then you'll do your lists and then you
follow the time management and then you
have your coaching call and you know
you're never going to feel better
because there's intrinsically something
wrong with them with the orientation of
personal growth but that's the that's
that very one end the other end is that
you are intrinsically interested in your
development human development and skill
development and in service right and so
you develop yourself for the sake of
others for the sake of your best self
for the sake of you know why not
essentially so that's the full spectrum
of personal growth but nowhere on that
spectrum is it Pleasant really right so
when your idea of relationship changes
because maybe you've had enough personal
growth for the time being
or you've won yourself out and
only so much a human can do till they
need some break or some rest because you
wouldn't do personal growth every day
all day in any other domain right you
wouldn't work out every day all day or
you know acquire a new skill every day
all day so if your idea of a purpose in
a relationship changes but first doesn't
then you become incompatible that's one
of the things that can happen where you
go well I'd actually just like a little
bit of fun and an easy time and I don't
like it Pleasant and would like to come
home and not have to work and and maybe
I'd like to catch a breath ever so often
and the night sleep without waiting for
the next upset right so so at that point
you and if she goes yeah it would be
nice I think that would be lovely
I don't know how we'll do that but I'm
up for that then you'd go and do some
relationship counseling or something and
figure out how can you create peace and
breath and you know all of that kind of
stuff that's possible great if not then
you'll break up right but if she says no
I like this what demonstrates that she
likes it even though she might say that
she doesn't and you are done then that's
one consideration right however the
other consideration is that if you've
entered a relationship for the sake of
personal growth like I was asking you
somewhat in jest earlier or if your
masochist right there is a bit of that
in there you have to look at why have
you chosen a woman who is that difficult
to deal with right and I'm sure we could
find the answer probably in your
upbringing somewhere else usually how it
goes we pick people who replicate the
patterns of our childhood and so now you
can look at the fact that you are
probably seeking love the way you
received love as a child which is
probably through conflict and somebody
nagging and being you know demanding
things of you that you maybe can bring
but don't really want to bring you
always feel a little bit bad and
insufficient so you need to grow a
little bit more you know all of that and
that's a losing battle because as long
as you engage in that you're going to be
stuck in that particular pattern and
there's no pushing through